RICK: What do we got here?
I found-- in a foreclosed
house that I bought,
I was kind of cleaning out a
bunch of junk in there and came
across this book
in a closet, kind
of stuffed in the back corner.
And boom, that's
what I came across.
Whoa-- a Martha
Washington $1 bill.
This is pretty amazing.
COREY: She looks really like
George Washington, though,
doesn't she?
RICK: Show a little respect.
I'm just saying
that her hair sucks.
That's all.
WOMAN: Hm.
Coming the pawn shop today to
sell this dollar that I found
with Martha Washington on it.
Hoping to sell the
dollar for about $1,500.
It'll be a nice little cushion.
I'll probably buy
something cool,
you know, maybe a hot
tub or a pool table
or something like that
to go with the house.
RICK: This is back when
we used to care about what
our money looked like.
BRYAN: Yeah, this is gnarly.
This is technically the only
woman that's been on a US bill.
I mean, they just
announced that they're
most likely going to put a
woman on the $10 bill now.
I heard that.
No, it's just an
incredibly good shape.
Luckily it was in this book.
How much are you looking
to get out of it?
You know, I looked
online a little bit.
And what I could see is it, you
know, was worth around $1,500.
COREY: I mean, it's
in really good shape.
Do we need to get it graded?
Well, that's the weird thing.
When it's in this good
of shape, you really
do need to get it graded.
And there's 10 grades
of a pristine bill.
I mean, this thing
could be worth
anywhere from between
$1,000 and $10,000.
$10,000?
Oh, my gosh.
It all depends
on how it grades.
Out and there's a
lot of variables
when it comes to paper money.
I have a friend who's in town
right now, and he grades bills.
I'm going to get him down here.
He'll tell me what grade
it is and help me out
with the price a little bit.
And we'll go from there, OK?
- Perfect.
Sounds good.
Thanks.
Be right back.
So hearing that could be worth
$10,000, I'm pretty stoked.
That'd be amazing.
Grading paper money is a
really, really tricky business.
So I'm calling it
a friend of mine
who does this for a living.
How's it going, buddy?
Hey, Rick.
Nice to meet you.
Peter.
Bryan.
This is the, you
know, Martha $1 bill.
It's in great shape.
And-- but we are
[inaudible] with paper money
and you guys and your
little grading weirdness.
Sure.
This is fantastic.
My name is Peter Treglia.
And I work for a company called
Stack's Bowers Galleries.
I'm an expert in rare United
States paper currency.
Well, this is an 1891
$1 silver certificate.
Well, the overall condition
is pretty fantastic, actually.
- Grab yo a tray real quick.
- Yeah, please.
Thank you.
I brought my light here.
OK, so as you know,
paper currency
is-- it's very fragile.
Unlike coins, you can
kind of fool around.
You can iron.
You can enhance the
condition of a bill.
But-- well, this is
actually really--
this is really,
really high grade.
At first glance, appears
to be flawless, and if so,
could be worth
upwards of $20,000.
Wow.
It is in absolutely
awesome condition.
The best a bill can be is
gem crisp uncirculated.
And the worst is a poor.
This is kind of towards
the top end of the range.
BRYAN: OK.
PETER TREGLIA: However, it
does have a slight, very
slight, centerfold,
which takes it out
of the uncirculated category.
It is not in the top range.
As far as value, I would put
a conservative retail value
around $1,500.
OK.
- But it's a cool find here.
- Yeah.
I mean, I'm stoked.
I just love the fact
that you're seeing Martha
Washington is on a centerfold.
[laughter]
Thanks, man, appreciate it.
- [inaudible], Rick.
- Thank you, buddy.
- Corey.
It's a pleasure.
- Thanks, Peter.
Nice meeting you.
- Take care.
If the shop is able
to acquire this bill,
I think it's a
fantastic buy for them.
They should have no
issues selling it quickly.
So the man said to $1,500.
What do you say, man?
Yeah, he said $1,500 was
a fair retail value, OK?
And I have to make a living.
So I'll give you $800,
$800?
Oh, man, you're killing me.
You just got offered
$800 for a $1 bill--
--that you found.
Yeah, I get you guys
got to make a living.
But come on, man.
$1,400.
Tell you what, I'll
have a grand for it.
I think it'll sell really
quick because they're
talking about putting Harriet
Tubman on the $10 bill now.
So there's some more
interest in this bill.
Can you do $1,200, man?
I will go $1,100.
I won't go a penny more.
That's what I can do.
I did find it in
the book, so I can't
really complain about that, so.
- All right, deal.
Thank you guys, man.
Come with me, and
we'll do some paperwork.
Walked in the shop with
a book and a dollar bill,
and now I'm leaving with
$1,100 in my pocket. his.